[موسيقى]
35 الف هذا الرقم هو عدد القرارات اللي
اتخذها الشخص في اليوم الواحد
قرارات ممكن تكون بسيطه زي انك تكمل وتسمع
باقي كلامي او لا او وش تتغدى وايش تتعشى
الليله لكن في قرارات مختلفه تتعلق بردود
فعلنا على مواقف شخصيه زي الغضب او صدمه
او لا مبالاه
والسؤالي للمفترض نساله انفسنا ليش اتخذنا
هالقرارات اصلا وليش تعاملنا مع الامور
بهالطريقه هالسؤال يمكن الكثير ما يوقف
ويسال نفسه يمكن انا خايف من الاجابه او
لانه يتوقع انه هذا انا انا كده اتصرف وما
في سبب وراها شيء او لانه وقع الحياه
السريع يخلينا في حاله ركض دائمه وما نقدر
نوقف وناخذ دقيقه ونحاول نفهم انفسنا
[موسيقى]
ادم معي انا محمد الحاج بنحاول نتعرف على
الاسباب العلميه وراء ردود افعالنا
ومشاعرنا وقراراتنا بعيدا عن الفضفضه
والوعظ والمسكنات محتوى يساعدك في التعرف
على نفسك وعلى الاخرين
وتوصل لحياه طيبه وشخصيه ناضجه تابعوا ادم
على كل منصات